i think also when it comes to identity
uh one thing that i've found is that
like for for people who are interested
in like getting things done and
productivity and like self-improvement
and all that all that stuff
there is kind of a sort of
super identity in a way that sits above
the specific
identities which is sort of like a
i'm a person that gets things done i'm a
productive person i'm a sort of
whatever
that that means that kind of anything
underneath that which is basically
everything else in life becomes easier
to do whereas i find with people who
have told themselves that they are a
procrastinator oh i'm just so
unproductive oh i could never do that
it becomes so hard to then do all of the
other things like health and wealth and
like caring about relationship like all
of the other stuff around what makes a
good life is harder to do if you have an
identity of someone who does not have
their [ __ ] together
proverbially i don't know if that's
something that you've found at all yeah
absolutely you can have set sort of core
beliefs about yourself from from that
came from you know maybe early in
childhood and they've just persisted and
then and they can really we don't think
about them all the time so we're not
always even aware of them you know in
therapy we'll spend sometimes a fair
amount of time sort of trying to work
out what those core beliefs are for
someone and i'm really sort of trying to
get right down to it and once we get
there there's so often this sort of
light bulb moment people where they
think yes and because you don't really
think about your core beliefs
all the time sometimes never at all but
they're that template that was perhaps
set up for you early in life that is
is your template for the world so it's
your idea of
they're often i am statements so
um it might be i don't know if it was
something negative it might be i am
unlovable or i am um unlikable or
something or it might be what to expect
from other people so other people will
abandon me or other people will
you know um hurt me or something or
something about the world so the world
is a dangerous place or something like
that so those those core beliefs are the
things that kind of sit under the
surface and influence the choices that
we make but we don't necessarily
consciously think about why we're making
those choices we have an urge and we go
with it because we always did
um so so yeah that's sort of all of that
identity stuff it's a big part of what
happens in therapy but we can do that
kind of thing um
in a self-help approach so with
journaling and things like that you know
you can really reflect on some of your
own
you know choices or the the cycles that
you seem to get stuck in and you're not
really sure how to break it
getting it down on paper something we do
in therapy a lot is getting a bird's eye
view you literally draw maps of um
behavior patterns and and then you look
down at it and you go
oh that's how i can break it there's
there's the exit okay now i know what i
need to do um which can be really
helpful so there's a lot of that in the
book where there's a lot of things like
journal prompts they're just questions
for you to sit down and go okay
let's answer these in 10 minutes and
maybe you might have that moment when
you go
ah okay yeah i think journaling prompts
are such an underrated like
technique because like i i've i've come
across a lot of gender problems and as i
was reading through the book i was like
oh these prompts are really good and
then i didn't do anything with them but
i know if i just sat with any one of
them for 10 minutes and actually just
answered it i'd get so much clarity on
like stuff in my life yeah and it just
feels like and anytime i've done that in
the past i've always
felt like damn i'm really glad i did
this i really should do this more often
yeah
and that's where doing this sort of you
know the the therapy thing even though
there's not a specific problem that
you're really trying to fix sometimes it
can be that sort of introspection and
and learning about yourself in the way
that you might with journaling um
where you just have someone to answer or
ask those questions but then also
reflect back on what they're hearing and
things like that you know a therapist
can be a mirror essentially where they
reflect back to you what they're hearing
from you and sometimes that can be quite
surprising what what you realize you're
sort of giving out hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day